hey if you're going through a difficult
time trials and tribulations they will
come you need to understand that and
know that God is not always just going
to take you out of it because he wants
to teach you endurance so that you will
be able to overcome the challenges that
are in front of you not just to sort out
the situation you're in right now
I'm going to read a quote for you from
my book called bold Pursuit that I want
you to listen to
through trials we learn that we can
never find true joy and peace from
temporary things
joy and peace come only from God even in
the middle of a storm
Jesus said I I said these things to you
that your joy may be full
your joy doesn't come from things from
people from this temporary World it
cannot if it does there's a problem with
your relationship with God
in him is everything you need
I love you guys and I'll see you in the
next video bye